[Musique]
on
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat ravi de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro d'on va plus loin édition
spéciale ce soir dans au vpn une heure
pleine consacrer à ses relations plus
tendues que jamais entre le sénat et
l'exécutif
on est encore dans les suites de la
sphère benalla le sénat a décidé de
saisir la justice
ce n'est pas une surprise pour ce qui
est des cas d'alexandre benalla et
devint son crâne en revanche ça l'est
davantage pour ce qui est des trois
hauts responsables de l'elysée
la majorité présidentielle ne décolère
pas edouard philippe à boycotter les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement au
sénat tout à l'heure richard ferrand
annuler sa conférence commune avec
gérard larcher benjamin griveaux dénonce
une instrumentalisation à des fins
politiques
stanislas guérini par le même de procès
politique je ne suis en guerre contre
personne répond gérard larcher pourtant
c'est bien ce mot qui revient dans la
bouche des observateurs de la vie
politique
senna exécutif la guerre et elle déclaré
c'est la question que nous posons ce
soir dont on va plus loin
#ows pl si vous souhaitez réagir sur
twitter d'abord retour sur les faits
avec fabien becker pour l'elysée c'est
un camouflet
jeudi matin le bureau du sénat décide de
transmettre à la justice
outre les dossiers d'alexandre benalla
et de vincent kraz celui du directeur de
cabinet des manuels macron patrick
strzoda tous suspectés de faux
témoignages également transmises au juge
les cas du secrétaire général de
l'elysée alexis colère et du chef du
gspr le général lavergne mais avec des
réserves
un certain nombre d'éléments sont
identifiés mais ils ne sont pas
suffisants pour considérer qu'il ya une
suspicion de faux témoignages avéré à ce
stade c'est à dire que là aussi nous
transmettons à la justice une décision
qui braquent l'exécutif l'après-midi
edouard philippe décident de boycotter
les questions d'actualité au sénat
une absence guère apprécié des sénateurs
j'aimerais pouvoir répondre à votre
collègue
allez dit les membres du gouvernement
présents dénonce une nouvelle fois une
croisade politique c'est une décision
politique
il faut que bureau du sénat l'assument
comme telle elle ne repose sur aucun
fondement ni en fait ni en droit au fond
à l'issue de cette procédure les masques
tombent
on est dans un instrumentalisation à des
fins politiques
la tension monte d'un cran quand vient
le tour du président de l'assemblée
nationale d'attaquer la chambre haute
richard ferrand devait accompagner le
président du sénat à lille pour une
rencontre avec des étudiants ce vendredi
il annule via communiqué prenant acte de
la décision du bureau du sénat
d'utiliser les fonctions de contrôle
parlementaire à des fins politiciennes
le président de l'assemblée nationale
estime que ce choix empêche la tenue de
ce débat républicain avec des étudiants
considérant que l'on ne peut
simultanément à baisser et promouvoir le
parlement gérard larcher annonce en fin
de journée qu'il maintient de son côté
le déplacement sur fond d'une crise
désormais grande ouverte entre le sénat
et la majorité présidentielle est avec
nous pour le grand débat spécial devait
pl ce soir jean marc gabouty bonsoir
sénateurs rdse de la haute-vienne vice
président du sénat est donc membre de ce
bureau du sénat jérôme bascher bonsoir
sénateurs et l'aisne l'oise membre de la
commission des finances stéphane bern et
bonsoir directeur de la rédaction
parisienne de ouest france
caroline michel aguer bon soit celle du
service affaires à l'ops oms va tout de
suite regardé la une de cette semaine
spéciale immobiliers tout ce qui change
vous pourrez aussi trouver un dossier
sur l'état de la gauche et l'union
impossible jérôme fourquet bonsoir et du
soin avoue également directeur du
département opinion de l'ifop et auteur
de ce livre
l'archipel français boycott des
par edouard philippe richard ferrand qui
annule sa conférence avec gérard larcher
des mots très forts de benjamin griveaux
des tweets incendiaires tout l'après
midi des membres de la république en
marche
jérôme bascher comment vous qualifier ce
qui se passe je trouve qu'il y à un
manque de maturité de la république en
marche sur ce dossier le suivant
scrupuleusement la constitution les
règles du sénat et l'article
40 du code de procédure pénale celui là
même que certains avaient reproché à
patrick strzoda de ne pas suivre dans la
sphère benalla est bien là nous
appliquons complètement la constitution
les règles la loi il n'y a rien à redire
je suis un peu déçu que benjamin
griveaux encore lui le multirécidiviste
de la déclaration malencontreuse nous
disent que ont fait pas ce qu'il faut
que c'est un procès politique il ya des
contrevérités il l'avait déjà dit
lorsqu'il n'avait pas lu le rapport de
la commission denquête en disant il ya
des contre vérités dans ce rapport on le
démontrera quelques semaines après on
attend toujours qu'il le démontre il le
répète et ce n'est pas en répétant des
bêtises que ça devienne vérité benjamin
griveaux qui le dit les masques plus là
la réaction les réactions peuvent
paraître excessive
il faut voir quand même qu'on s'est un
petit peu emballé passant d'une affaire
pénale à je dirais à une mise en
accusation des collaborateurs de
l'elysée avec des suspicions mais il
écrit dans le texte
ils ont menti moi je m'inscris en faux
contre cela et contrairement à ce que
dit ce monsieur sueur ou d'autres je
considère que ce n'est pas de certitude
absolue au jeu mais je considère après
avoir lu robbie mme may auditions les
rapports que les conclusions auxquelles
sont arrivés la commission denquête ou
du moins ce qui a été écrit dans le
document final
il y assure nombre d'inexactitudes il y
à des interprétations tout à fait
contestable et il y a des assimilations
que voilà qui sont tout à fait également
regrettable donc moi je conteste le faut
on vous parlait de réaction excessive on
parlait du bureau du sénat vous parlez
des réactions je parle des réactions du
président de l'assemblée nationale
on voit là je veux dire que on est dans
un pays qui est confronté à d'autres
problèmes donc il faut raison garder
ceci étant ceux ci étant sur la position
prise par le sénat
qui a été prise en bureau ne conteste
pas du tout la procédure qui a été
utilisé une procédure très très
juridique parce que finalement les
collaborateurs du programme arbitres ont
tous dit la même chose sauf qu'alain qui
a fait référence et une circulaire de
juillet 2017 et les autres pas donc ça a
permis de le mettre un petit peu plus
sur l'échafaud et les autres de gommer
du sommet de gommer effectivement leur
nom moi j'ai pas de certitude sur tout
mais j'ai une certitude si vous laissez
que la thèse qui permet de d'impliquer
ces personnes est d'une très grande
fragilité
il y aura peut-être un jour en effet
boomerang pour le sénat reprécisons
quand même pour nos téléspectateurs
effectivement y'a quand même des nuances
1 dans la décision du bureau du sénat
patrick strzoda et envoyé devant la
justice pour suspicion de faux
témoignage mais pour alexis colère et le
général lavergne ce sont seulement les
déclarations qui sont adressés au
procureur
et quand même la nuance de la mesure
qu'est ce que vous en pensez car les
niches à la guerre je pense que le sénat
a fait ce qu'il fallait et c'est à la
justice de se prononcer c'était il y
avait un certain nombre de faits les
faits sont assez indiscutable que ce
soit monsieur colère au monsieur strauss
kahn de manière différente mais monsieur
colère en particulier qui nous dit qu
alexandre bensalah n'était pas le garde
du corps d'emmanuel macron alors qu'on a
des photos des images montrant qu'ils se
positionnent à l'épaule comme on dit
comme le siège du président deuxième
chose on nous dit monsieur colère avait
déclaré que monsieur benalla ne s'était
jamais occupé de la sécurité à l'elysée
alors là nous avons pléthore de
témoignages y compris dans des enquêtes
qu'on a fait
deux syndicalistes de membres du du sld
donc du service de la protection disant
que benalla s'était présenté à eux comme
l'homme de macron dans ce sujet de la
sécurité
j'ai moi même recueilli des témoignages
de personnes me disaient qu'ils
assistaient quasiment à toutes les
réunions à l'église et donc deux fêtes y
avait un questionnement et je trouve que
la séparation du pouvoir n'est pas
respectée là par les membres de la
majorité ils ont à respecter le travail
de la justice
et est-ce qu'on doit parler de sueur et
l'exécutif stéphane bern comment vous la
voyez cette réaction de tous ses membres
de la république en marge de la majorité
présidentielle puisque l'exécutif c'est
la majorité présidentielle a qui est en
question avec avec des choses quand même
qu'ils sont assez saisissante parce
qu'on a évoqué les propos de benjamin
griveaux mais vous avez le président de
l'assemblée nationale richard ferrand
qui parle de kid qui dit puisqu'on a vu
dans votre sujet que les fonctions de
que les fonctions de contrôle
parlementaire du sénat avaient été
utilisés à des fins politiciennes
je trouve que c'est je trouve que c'est
grave les propos sont très forts et on
voit bien coller les actions ou les
réactions qui ont qui ont été mises en
place dès aujourd'hui sont quand même
d'ampleur on al'impression alors vous
utilisez le terme de deux guerres entre
autres l'exécutif mais on a surtout
l'impression d'assister aux veaux au bal
diplomatique qui précède justement les
déclarations guerre avec les postures
quand on voit richard ferrand qui ne
veut plus accompagné gérard larcher à
lille dans son déplacement
edouard philippe quinault qui ne vient
pas on voit qu'il ya une réaction très
forte qui est d'ordre de la symbolique
est en fait qui consiste pour la
république en marche à dévider la pelote
dévider la pelote qu'elle avait
entrepris de dévider dès le début de
cette affaire en dix ans il y à une
tentative d' acharnement contre contre
la personne du président de la
république la vérité la vérité des prix
c'est c'est à la justice aujourd'hui de
dire ce qu'il en est c'est à dire que on
est dans une affaire qui va qui est en
cours de ju dire qui est en train de se
jurer saisir il ne se judiciarise et
pardon qui est-ce qui avait déjà
commencé pour alexandre biennale à la
présomption d'innocence elle s'applique
à tous les citoyens y compris alexandre
bien à la iq ont pris à patrick strzoda
et à tous ceux qui ont été cités
et c'est au travail c'est à la justice
de faire son travail en toute
indépendance
est ce ce dont ceux dont personnellement
je ne doute pas je voudrais en revenir à
cette définition de la situation jérôme
fourquet comment vous voyez cela on a
parlé de crise ouverte envoyée en titre
certains disent déclaration de guerre
comment vous voyez cela c'est une
une péripétie supplémentaire qui n'ont
mais qui s'abat de ces d'accord qui
s'abat sur le gouvernement un
gouvernement qui pensait avoir repris la
main depuis le lancement du grand débat
scénario qui sait qu'il ya qui a volé en
éclat samedi dernier avec les images
qu'on a vu sur les champs-elysées et
leur le retour sur paris en catastrophe
des manuels macro et depuis lors on a le
sentiment effectivement que entre les
déboires du ministre de l'intérieur qui
était là aussi très passe très fortement
passer sur le gril par les sénateurs il
y accueillir
et puis cette ce nouveau rebondissement
dans la sphère ben alla aujourd'hui
l'exécutif est de nouveau envoyé dans
les cordes comme il l'avait été avant ou
pendant la sphère des gilets jaunes et
c'est sans doute cet état de nervosité
que traduit également que traduisait
également les réactions à chaud d'un
certain nombre de membres éminents de la
majorité parce que
on sent très bien que le
voilà le la tension est à son paroxysme
dans le rang et que c'est le coeur même
du dispositif macro niant qui est
aujourd'hui atteint c'est à dire qu' on
n'est pas à l'abri de voir le secrétaire
général de l'elysée directeur le
directeur de cabinet aller devant le
juge pour s'expliquer alors même que sur
les autres fronts
la situation est loin d'être stabilisée
on y reviendra
je voudrais qu'on écoute quelques
quelques autres règles sur les co
rapporteurs de la commission denquête se
disent se plier au droit
rien qu'au droit notre journaliste tom
tran huy a pu interroger tout à l'heure
jean pierre sueur dont vous parliez et
lui la sueur il n'a fait que son travail
de parlementaire on l'écouté je vous
fait réagir ensuite est-ce qu'on veut
que dans ce pays il y ait un pouvoir de
contrôle du parlement
si on veut qu'il n'y ait pas de pouvoir
de contrôle du parlement qu'on le dise
mais alors on va être dans une drôle de
république ça va pas être dans notre
tradition et cl aux pouvoirs de contrôle
est exercé par des parlementaires
ce sont des parlementaires qui ont tous
une étiquette politique
mais ils sont pas là au nom de leur
étiquette politique combien de fois
votre attire le dire à monsieur
marseille qui dit voilà c'est la
collusion mais c'est pas du tout la
collusion nous sommes des parlementaires
nous faisons notre boulot de
parlementaires qui est de rechercher la
vérité nous l'avons fait et alors
aujourd'hui que voulez-vous que disent
le bureau il n'allait pas contredire un
rapport que le gouvernement n'a pas
contredit que rennes n'a pas contredit
alors jean pierre sueur a l'air de dire
que ça a été simple sauf que nos
confrères du parisien croit savoir que
les débats ont quand même été houleux ce
matin et jean marc gabouty vous allez me
dire si vous confirmez ou pas selon
certains participants gérard larcher
comme valérie létard ont déployé tous
leurs efforts pour dégager des arguments
juridiques susceptibles de limiter les
charges retenues contre les
collaborateurs de l'elysée sont des
informations de nos confrères du
parisien est ce que vous confirmez cela
écouter géant larcher et valérie létard
qui n'étaient pas tous les deux dans la
position peu tu as plus confortable
on essayait de je dirais d'avoir une
ligne directrice qui était le droit oui
et ils ont été amenés à séparer monsieur
strzoda des autres puisque non monsieur
colère du gérant lavergne ont disparu
uniquement sur susurre en fait c'est à
dire que ils ont considéré que monsieur
strzoda faisait référence à trois
missions de monsieur benalla alors qu'il
y en avait cinq dans la note
sauf lorsqu'on regarde en réalité c'est
exactement la même chose mais ça c'est
mon point de vue personnel et donc en
dix ans les autres n'ont pas cité la
note donc on les écarte en fait c'est ça
la question
c'était il était forcément à la
recherche je le regrette mais il ya des
tensions politiques qui ont existé je ne
m'y connais pas tout
ils étaient à la recherche du compromis
impossible un compromis impossible parce
que c'était difficile c'est vrai de dire
que nous ont pas suivis dans ce que j'ai
exposé puisque jeudi que la commission
comme et un certain nombre d'erreurs
moi je ne vais pas prétendre que j'ai
pas dire la commission a menti mais je
reste au niveau de l'erreur bon
d'erreurs d'appréciation et ne pas avoir
approfondi un certain nombre de un
certain nombre de choses il était
difficile d'aller contre ce qu'ils
avaient fait la commission puisque ce
avait été rendu public et ç'avait été
approuvée même si c'est tout le monde
n'est pas détaillé tout le monde à lui
est difficile à prouver à la dignité
pour 3 abstentions rose abstention rares
sorties repas dès votre contrat c'est
pas une marque ce n'est pas une grande
attention ce n'est pas une approbation
c'est une autorisation de publier sur
verre tard sauf que
c'est à dire les gens l'autorisation de
publier ils ont ça en réunion et leur
demande l'autorisation de publier un
quart d'heure après une demi-heure après
ça pas été le cas de cette commission un
nom n'a pas été et documents
d'autorisation publiés ils ont ils n'ont
pas étudié pendant pendant trois
semaines un bon donc toute autorisation
de publier ok il ya des gens qui ont eu
la surprise de découvrir cette cad
je dirais du président du groupe de
l'union centriste yvan de la commission
des lois de découvrir le texte
dans le document donc voilà donc moi je
crois qu'en droit le bureau du sénat
fait ce qu'il pouvait il ya il ya eu des
échanges qui sont restés qui sont restés
apaisé correct chacun se respecte au
sein du port mais s'il est sur le fond
je pense qu'il ya des faiblesses moi je
ne souhaite pas que ça revienne comme un
effet boomerang dans le sénat parce que
je défends l'institution jeu
je respecte beaucoup le mes collègues du
bureau et en particulier le président
gérard larcher
mais je pense qu'on fait une erreur non
je crois que le bureau s'est exprimé il
a chacun a défendu sa position
le rapport avait été publiée adopté il
était pluridisciplinaire pluri coloré il
y avait vraiment tout le monde autour de
la table à chaque fois ce qui était
surprenant c'était effectivement le fait
qu'à chaque fois on apprenait des choses
supplémentaires et ce qui est estimée
par la commission denquête je crois et
c'est comme ça que j'ai compris le
communiqué de presse de la présidence du
sénat c'est que dorénavant c'est à la
justice de pouvoir enquêter plus loin le
sénat n'a pas des pouvoirs d'enquêté
judiciaire il ne va pas sur pièces et
sur place faire une perquisition il ne
fait pas de garde à vue une nappe à ses
capacités là sa capacité c'est
d'entendre sous serment et de demander
des pièces et des pièces d'ailleurs
certaines qui ont été demandés à la
justice certaines et la justice les a
transmises
il ya donc bien une bonne idée de la
bonne séparation du pouvoir le juge a
estimé que les pièces qu'il avait par
devers lui devais vous pouvait être
transmise à la commission d' enquête du
sénat
tout cela est parfaitement respectée je
comprends que cela puisse énerver mais
si on veut défendre le parlement il faut
aller jusqu'au bout
jean marc gabouty exprimer il est
heureusement son indépendance sans
droits c'était le cas de tous les
membres
et je dis bien de tous les membres
guerre du bureau du sénat les sénateurs
sont connus pour être indépendant je
crois que les membres du bureau du sénat
sont des sénateurs expérimenté encore
plus indépendant que les guerres bras de
fer crise ouverte les termes 10 fermes
et très clairement cette décision est un
tournant dans les relations entre le
sénat et l'elysée certains observateurs
parlent déjà de conséquence politique
majeure et notamment sur la réforme des
institutions qui se prépare emmanuel
macron va-t-il riposté je vais vous
poser la question dans un instant
d'abord on va écouter la réaction de
patrick kanner président du groupe
socialiste au sénat
moi je pense que nous fait plutôt un
procès en sorcellerie est ce que le
sénat dérange dans son rôle d' équilibre
des pouvoirs
est-ce qu'il a le droit de travailler de
manière un peu autonome sans la pression
de l'exécutif est ce qu'il a le droit de
dire l'exécutif mais peut-être qu'il ya
eu des problèmes de dysfonctionnement au
sein de l'elysée sur la question
d'insécurité du président bon si on
dérange je le regrette mais en tout cas
nous sommes restés manifestement droits
dans leurs bottes car les michel aguer
le sénat dérange c'est marrant parce
qu'il ya un précédent que personne
n'évoque jamais ça m'étonne toujours
beaucoup c'est le cas de la commission
d' enquête menée par bernard cazeneuve
il ya de ça une dizaine d'années sur l'
affaire karachi
on était exactement dans le même
contexte une affaire judiciaire
bernard cazeneuve qui était à l'époque
dans l'opposition qui mène une
commission denquête très forte
il en a fait même la relation dans un
livre où il ne fait pas comment dia il
ne cache pas son ambition qui était à
l'époque de relancer l' enquête
judiciaire et de fait ça en partie
abouti et on ne raconte jamais que ce
n'est pas la première fois
je veux dire les commissions d'enquêté
parlementaires elles ne sont pas faites
juste pour je ne sais pas parler de des
comptes de la sécu en face ans elles
sont aussi enfin on attend du parlement
et je pense que les citoyens à temps du
parlement au sens large c'est-à-dire
assemblée et sénat qu'il soit un contre
pouvoir qu'ils fassent leur mission de
contrôle dès lors qu'elle est en effet
classé cet exécutif là qui ne supporte
pas qu'on surveille ce qu'il fait ou
finalement c'est un peu saoul c'est
souvent le cas vous souriez c'est ça je
à ce problème
on moi je suis jamais assez à votre
sentiment que cet exécutif n'a pas
d'expérience ce président de la
république
on n'a pas beaucoup l'habitude de la
contradiction ni de l'échec excusez moi
je le dis elle a l'habitude du 49 3 pour
passer ses lois mais je ne fais pas que
ça touche que je lui même parlé de
gamineries hier sa touche quelque chose
qu'il y ait très personnelle il faut
toujours remettre ça dans le contexte de
sa première déclaration qui était elle
même assez ahurissante qui est un peu le
péché originel de cette histoire qui est
tout le monde s'en souvient à la maison
de l'amérique latine où il dit le seul
responsable c'est moi donc c'est bien le
président de la république a
personnalisé
je suis celui qui embauchent alexandre
benalla si ils veulent qu il vient de me
chercher alors dire la dramatisation de
7000 ya deux responsabilités que ce qui
se passe actuellement on va le chercher
là mais évidemment la bordée alors deux
choses
yahia 2 justement revenir à la suite
parce que finisse et caroline mais si il
est de ce tempérament là comme vous le
décrivez quelle peut être la suite
qu'elles peuvent être deux erreurs
majeures de l'exécutif la première c'est
que les gens comme monsieur alexandre
benalla ne doivent jamais jamais rentré
dans la lumière jamais sinon ça pose des
problèmes donc le premier mais quand on
l'autorisent à les mettre un brassard
est allé à une manifestation sans
contrôle c'est une première erreur grave
de l'exécutif du je pense à
l'inexpérience
la deuxième erreur c'est ce sentiment un
peu de toute puissance du président de
la république qui dit je suis le
responsable qu'on vient de me chercher
comme s'il n'avait pas réalisé qu'ils
avaient un sénat que y'avait un
parlement qui avait une justice et que
s'ils avaient défait des questions des
réponses se chercher et très
concrètement que peut-il se passer
peut-être jérôme fourquet on peut nous
éclairer sur cette question quelles sont
les clefs la riposte possible pour
emmanuel macron
on pense évidemment à cette réforme des
institutions qui pourrait faire du mal
au sénat oui non évidemment ça peut être
ça peut être une option
l'autre option plus plus rapprochée
c'est une prise de parole alors dans le
ton qui devra être adéquat même si
encore une fois j'insiste sur le fait
que cette cet événement survient dans un
calendrier qui est déjà extrêmement
tendue pour le président de la
république tout le monde a les yeux
rivés sur ce qui va se passer dans 48
heures dans les rues de certaines
grandes villes de france et notamment de
paris
on a un premier ministre de l'intérieur
qui était mis sur la sellette et qui est
fragilisée on a d un terme aux amants
sur la tête de liste pour les élections
européennes
on a un remue-méninges permanent sur
comment on sort du grand débat et
comment on arrive à proposer des choses
aux français qui ne suscite pas la
déception alors que les revendications
premières encore et toujours porte sur
la fiscalité etc on sait qu'il ya pas de
marge de manoeuvre est donc je suis pas
convaincu
quand toute logique le président devrait
riposter de manière très massives
vis-à-vis du sénat et de nourrir 7
cette rhétorique et puis le médiatique
sur le bras de fer et la guerre entre
les cas par le passé
il met alors parlé de peut-être
apprentissage de la fonction on peut se
dire peut-être que les réactions vont
être plus modérée cette fois ci encore
une fois puisque il est sans doute
urgent de ne pas multiplier les fronts
de la part d'un président qui est quand
même aujourd'hui assez affecté un
couteau on va pas revenir sans ces temps
dessus mais les images le télescopage
entre les images de la mongie et des
champs elysées qui brûle on fait des
dégâts très très importants dans
l'opinion
ajouter la crise à la crise mon avis
c'est pas forcément une sage décision
mais tout le monde n'est pas toujours
sage
non moi je ne peux que souscrire à ce
que vient de dire jean fourquet je pense
que c'est la voix de la raison en fait
c'est un cet épisode intervient à un
moment où la conjonction des planètes et
juste désastreuse c'est vraiment le pire
moment imaginables pour le président la
république
quel intérêt aurait-il à montrer les
muscles a essayé d'allumer un nouveau
contre feu alors qu'il a bien d'autres
choses
éminemment oui mais il ya un côté il ya
aussi une réaction à mon avis il ya une
dimension épidermique dans la réaction
ce qu est ce qui a été évoqué tout à
l'heure effectivement qik est liée aussi
aux au contexte d'une histoire qui ne
qui dure qui c'est qui qui s'est
déroulée sous forme d'un incroyable
feuilleton à chaque nouvel épisode
il ya des choses nouvelles qui sort du
des tiroirs et la position de l'elysée
l'exécutif la majorité présidentielle
dès le départ c'était quand même de dire
ça n'est pas une affaire d'état oui il
ya peut-être eu une dérive mais elle est
de l'ordre de la faute personnelle et il
n'y a pas de quoi en faire un plat sauf
que plus on avance et
et oui et puis qui se diffusent de
manière spectaculaire et alors juste à
peut-être un élément sur lequel
j'aimerais revenir c'est que oui
effectivement on a besoin que le
parlement exerce des fonctions de
contrôle
on a le besoin que le parlement
s'affirme sereine que kj choi et qui est
je trouve ça plutôt très bien sauf que
quand on parle du parlement dans le
parlement il ya deux chambres il ya le
sénat et l'assemblée esquissé au risque
est en train de se passer c'est que on
assiste aussi à une fracture assez
spectaculaire en tout cas là tout de
suite entre le sénat et l'assemblée or
on a on a on a besoin aussi pour que la
les institutions fonctionnent bien dans
ce pays qu'elle puisse travailler en
bonne intelligence et moi je jouais je
crains que ça ne laisse des traces sur
le long terme un moment où on aurait
plutôt besoin que que le que
l'institution soit soit forte
encore une fois par rapport au reste du
contexte
alors tout le monde derrière jean marc
gabouty oui mais moi je crois qu'on est
quand même dans dans une échelle
totalement disproportionnée je critique
et mena mais vous évoquez la commission
d' enquête sur l'affairé karachi au
pakistan avec un certain nombre de
cadres et d'ingénieurs français
tué dans un attentat là on est sûr je
dirais une des imprécisions des
omissions volontaires ou pas c'est ce
que dit la commission dans ses
contradictions
oui faut pas trop faire les
contradictions elles sont plutôt dans le
rapport mais bon ça c'est mon point de
vue mais sur sur des choses qui n'ont
pas été complètement dit c'est pas l'un
vers ce qui était des choses qui n'ont
pas été complètement beat reproche à
monsieur strzoda d'avoir cité trois
missions pour benalla au lieu de cinq
mots la vie des cités des 5 bon je crois
qu'il faut quand même ramener les choses
à leur juste proportion par rapport aux
problèmes auxquels nous sommes
confrontés
moi je ne souhaite pas et je pour ça que
je regrette la position du sénat je ne
souhaite pas qu'il y ait une bagarre
entre le sénat les visées d'assembler ce
qui se passe est inédite
mais au moment ciblés au moment où on
sentait qu'il y avait un rapprochement
sur les procédures entre le sénat et
assemblée nationale et où les relations
avaient été entre le sénat et l'exécutif
avait plutôt tendance à s'améliorer dans
le cadre législatif on prend première
lecture une loi importante à loi
mobilité donc techniquement c'était
peut-être pas le grand amour mais
techniquement il ya un ensemble de
choses qui s'améliorait dans le
fonctionnement du parlement et de son
partenariat avec l'exécutif
et on arrive à ce moment là et je lirai
autre réaction à vous soumettre celles
de marc fesneau ministre des relations
avec le parlement toujours au micro de
tam tran huy en salle des conférences
tout à l'heure est critique lui aussi
cette décision au bureau du sénat du
bureau du sénat lors ces mots ne sont
évidemment pas ceux de benjamin griveaux
évidemment je suis rassure que ce type
de décision ce genre de procès politique
qui peuvent être intentées à tel ou tel
permettent d'aider rehausser le niveau
du débat public et le débat politique et
je suis sûr que la raison va revenir ce
que le cette maison que je connais bien
est une maison qui normalement travail
avec raison et dans la volonté de
l'intérêt collectif
normalement mais pas cette fois alors
jérôme bascher la raison va revenir dans
cette maison alors d'une pharmacie se
tait pisode du point de vue du sénat est
terminée cette injustice sans saisir
donc il ya plus de commentaires à faire
politiquement ce n'est pas terminé mais
nous sommes en train d'examiner la loi
l'homme nous aurons
bientôt d'autres lois importantes et
nous travaillons avec le gouvernement
est encore là cet après midi je suis est
venue des l'hémicycle pour sur ce
plateau
tout se passe normalement dit
travaillons calmement mais nous ne
sommes pas dans un procès justement
travaillons à élaborer la loi avec la
sagesse qui caractérise de ces noirs et
quand richard avons une attaque d'une
agressivité inédite c'est à paraître
demain dans le figaro donc on va encore
et bien après demain on parlera d'autre
chose et la semaine prochaine ça ira
beaucoup mieux les esprits se seront
calmées et on sera revenu au travail
c'est l'état d'esprit qui est celui de
la majorité sénatoriale c'est l'état
d'esprit de tous les sénateurs qui eux
travaillent
oui pour rajouter sur un élément que
nous avons pas évoqué concernant le
degré de fébrilité elle à l'elysée et
qui qui explique ces actions il faut
aussi avoir en tête le fait qu'un
certain nombre de collaborateurs de
l'elysée sont partis ces derniers mois
ces dernières semaines et que donc on a
peut-être un dispositif élyséen qui est
moins solide qu'il y a qu il ya quelques
mois et là c'est une péripétie
supplémentaire qui vient déstabiliser ou
désorganisant encore un peu plus ce camp
là d'où le fait que et bien on est des
peut-être des réactions très vives parce
qu'on nous envoie là il ya une guerre
larvée qui nous est mené on essaie de
nous et ensemble c'est pas terminé
je voudrais juste répondre mon ambition
n'était pas de comparer évidemment une
affaire où il ya eu des morts à une
affaire où il n'y a pas de morts
mais néanmoins on aurait tort de penser
que c'est une affaire secondaire
pourquoi parce qu'elle touche à la
présidence de la république et en
particulier à la sécurité du président
de la république
quand vous êtes aux états unis vous avez
un organisme qui s'appelle le secret'
office qui emploie 7000 personnes
secretservice pardon et qui a tout
pouvoir tout pouvoir sur la sécurité du
président c'est à dire que monsieur tron
tout tranquille quand il va à l'étranger
le secret de service lui dit vous allez
de là à là et vous n'en bougeait pas ça
montre à quel point la sécurité du
président et ce genre de sujets ne sont
pas des sujets secondaires
or qu'est-ce qu'on découvre je te jure
comme le parjure devant le parlement que
ce cas il faut pas c'est pas parce qu'il
n'y a pas de morts que c'est un sujet
secondaire c'est juste pertes et
permettez moi de terminer on a dans ce
qu'elle a la preuve que ce pouvoir et
c'est pour ça depuis longtemps on tourne
autour du pot en disant affaire d'état
pas affaire d'état pourquoi c'est
symbolique parce que ça nous montre que
ce pouvoir sur un sujet aussi important
en particulier pour la vie démocratique
française a été près de confier des
responsabilités à un homme qui n'avait
visiblement pas les qualifications et ça
en dit beaucoup évidemment dans le fond
on pourrait dire ça n'est pas si grave
mais aller aux états unis dans le même
cas de figure
je n'en sais rien je veux pas faire de
presse qu'il faut suivre forcément non
des procédures de destitution ou je sais
pas quoi cimt rome s'était lancé dans
l'idée de déshabiller le secretservice
donc je pense qu'il ne faut pas même si
je ne mets pas sur le même coin
retraités d'affaires sur la question je
ne conteste pas qu'il y ait eu des
dysfonctions les dysfonctionnements
pardon avec la présence de monsieur mais
de là à l'elysée
mais je veux dire que entre les
dysfonctionnements et puis l'audition de
personnes qui ne l'ont pas maîtrisé dans
son dans son parcours qui n'ont pas
suffisamment surveillé et c'est la
responsabilité oui mais non ça je pense
qu'effectivement on peut leur reprocher
de ne pas avoir été suffisamment
vigilants par rapport au comportement de
monsieur benalla ensuite sur le reste il
ya des choses qui me paraissent
effectivement tout à fait tout à fait
contestable et il faut pas grossir les
reproches qui leur sont faits on peut
leur reprocher un manque de surveillance
et un manque de vigilance à l'égard de
monsieur benalla le montage qui a été
fait parce que je pensais quand même un
montage à mon sens ne tient pas
forcément la route
alors cette opposition entre le sénat et
l'exécutif ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
elles ne datent même pas de cette
affaire benalla le torchon brûle depuis
assez longtemps vous me direz ce que
vous en pensez depuis le début du
quinquennat
voyons pourquoi avec marie brémaud on en
parle après
ça y est de part et d'autre on lâche les
coûts mais les relations entre le sénat
et le gouvernement sont tumultueuses
depuis le début du quinquennat
en séance les passes d'armes sont
nombreuses les rappels à l'ordre aussi
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
rappellent que je vais sus fort de la
séance mais je rappelle à tous que c'est
moi qui préside la séance et moi sommes
les désaccords se succèdent au fil des
mois sur les territoires et leurs
représentations tout d'abord sur la
réforme des institutions également nous
devons donc nous employer à ce que le
sénat représentant les collectivités
territoriales de la république continue
à incarner par sa composition
l'ensemble des territoires de notre pays
au prétexte de la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires on ne doit pas condamner
au quasi silence certains territoires de
notre pays au prétexte que leur
démographie serait plus faible des
conflits qui s'affichent désormais au
grand jour
gérard larcher ironisant même sur le
bilan du président c'est vrai que les
2019 ne commence pas su sous les
meilleurs auspices pour notre pays on
peut parce que jouir l'état de la france
on est au fond le constat d'échec de ces
18 mois de présidence qui devait voir
l'avènement d'un monde nouveau souvenons
nous conquérant et ambitieux aujourd'hui
nul doute que l'ancien monde savoure sa
revanche et en doses plus que jamais le
rôle de contre-pouvoir stéphane bern est
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce que vous
diriez ski ce que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui cette crise ouverte ce bras
de fer finalement c'est le résultat de
ces longs mois de de division 2
dire de disputes non c'est un peu
enfantin comme terme en tout cas de bras
de fer
non je dirais pas ça parce que dire ça
ce sera accrédité la thèse qui
consisterait à dire que finalement le
sénat instrumentalisée pour des raisons
purement politiques cette affaire or le
départ de la faire c'est quand même bien
la faire mais n'a là il s'est passé
quelque chose qui méritait une enquête
parlementaire qui a été conduite voilà
après le que le torchon brûle entre le
sénat et l'exécutif depuis le début des
quinquas du quinquennat oui mais
pourquoi pas à cause de la sphère
benallal aucun lien la réalité c'est que
il faut quand même rappeler aux
téléspectateurs même s'ils ont
l'habitude de regarder un public sénat
et donc le c'est là que le sénat c'est
la chambre haute et que les sénateurs
sont élus par des grands électeurs qui
sont des élus locaux et donc le sénat la
fonction première du sénat c'est de
représenter les collectivités
territoriales et les territoires et oui
or la problématique en fait l ailier des
bleus le divorce ou le malentendu il a
eu lieu dès le début dès juillet 2017
au moment où emmanuel macron le
président convoque la première
conférence nationale des territoires que
tous les élus locaux appelé de leurs
voeux et qui trouvé ça fantastique et
que et que nous tous se sont dits
finalement le nouveau monde nous offre
des perspectives et des façons de
dialogue est très intéressante et dès le
lendemain ou le surlendemain il ya eu
toute une série d'annoncés qui ont
commencé qui prenait à contre-pied
cet espoir qui était né avec cette
élection sur le fait que finalement les
restrictions budgétaires à l'été allait
être supérieur ou les efforts financiers
demandés aux collectivités elle est bien
supérieure à ce qui avait été annoncé
pendant la campagne
puis il ya eu d'affaires des emplois
aidés puis il ya eu la réduction des
appels en disant se tourner ce sera
compensée par les offices hlm et tous et
tout s'est enchaîné à tous et toutes et
tous et toutes ces choses se sont
enchaînées et elles ont même donné lieu
un
un effet direct est quand même
intéressant c'est que la république en
marche aurait pu ou aurait dû obtenir de
bien meilleurs résultats aux
sénatoriales à l'automne
porté par la direction du président les
législatives mais non mais non mais non
et les logiciels des législatives ils
l'ont mis sur les sénatoriales sabam
archiduc aux élus locaux
juste avant et le résultat c'est qu'on a
deux chambres qui sont clairement
opposés au niveau politique ou alors
juste pour rebondir sur ce que ce qui
vient d'être dit effectivement il ya un
moment très important ces élections
sénatoriales où le sénat apparaît comme
un môle de résistance de ce qu'on
appelle l'ancien monde dans la nouvelle
terminologie face à face à la majorité
macro nien qui a tout emporté sur son
passage aux législatives et donc dès le
début il ya sept
bergé ils ont perdu des sénateurs ont
perdu également donc dès le début il ya
ce duo paul qui s'installe et on voit
que le sénat va être un contre-pouvoir
et comme ce qui a été rappelé il va
donner du fil à retordre dans dans la
suite du quinquennat donc c'est
peut-être aussi fort de cette histoire
là qu'aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
représentants de la macro n'y croit
déceler dans ce qui vient de se passer
les suites de cette guerre larvée
0-100 sujet marie vraiment parler de
revanche de lempdes qu'il ya en tout cas
les leçons avant de les donner il faut
les apprendre c'est sans doute cela qui
a été oublié en dit voilà on trouve être
on va faire table rase du passé c'était
n'importe quoi
notre valérie andré fort a changé les
codes a effectivement on a changé les
codes sans la changer d'abord le code de
la route avec les 80 kilomètres heure
qui n'a pas eu un grand succès on a
changé un certain nombre de d'éléments
sur la fiscalité ce qu'ils n'ont pas eu
forcément une grande popularité et ça a
donné effectivement 18 semaines
consécutives presque avec noël on dire
qu'il ya une petite trêve des confiseurs
qui est effectivement inédit en france
donc on n'a pas une revanche de l'ancien
monde
enfin faut quand même pas prendre tout
le monde pour des imbéciles
l'histoire de france elle a un sens
lésée institutions de la vème république
si elles ont duré aussi longtemps avant
que le nouveau monde n'apparaissent
c'est que peut-être ça crée des pôles de
stabilité y compris dans les
circonstances
ô combien plus difficile ô combien plus
dramatique
ces institutions elles sont fort qu'il
faut savoir les utiliser voilà les
manier non c'est pas une revanche
honnêtement ça pas l'intérêt sur un non
sens ça n'a pas de sens cet ancien monde
et ce nouveau monde c'est une totale
aberration mais parce qu'il ya une
conjonction ce que ben oui parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une association
quand même ps et d'air alors l air qui a
du mal à se refaire une santé et le ps
qui a eu du mal à vraiment existé donc
bien jean-pierre sueur jeux d'affilée il
existe et à travers lui le ps existe
c'est bien la seule en voilà seul
endroit
je dirai au niveau national où ils
arrivent à avoir voix au chapitre si
chacun a été élu démocratiquement et est
représenté ce n'est pas le nom mon sujet
le suivant c'est que effectivement à la
chambre des territoires qui est
effectivement un peu plus expérimentés
nous avons tous été ou presque quelques
exceptions non nous avons tous été élus
locaux nous avons tous dirigés des
exécutifs
bon alors c'est vrai que on peut dire
que c'était pas bien mais le fait et ça
c'est lié à la loi j'ai à dire sur
l'absence de cumul d'avoir une nouvelle
génération politique qui n'ont jamais
fait politique d'un côté et d'autre part
des gens qui n'ont jamais en plus
exercer parfois un mandat local et qui
ne peuvent plus le faire
un moment créer une déconnexion et puis
aspiré par un chef qui est charismatique
on peut dire ce qu'on veut mais le
maquereau et charismatique quand il fait
ses performances car ce sont des
performances réelles de 6h à 8h devant
les élus devant les français devant les
intellectuels on est bluffé
mais il est tout seul alors c'est une
pyramide hausse est un colosse emmanuel
macron aux pieds d'argile toute sa basse
ça ressemble à pas grand chose
quand l'heure vous leur demandez leur
avis sur un sujet qui n'a pas été
tranchée par le président de la
république la réponse est le président
s'exprimera moi je trouve génial et il
n'ya pas d'ironie dans ma voix d'un
point de vue du fonctionnement de la
démocratie française que gérard larcher
fini bas et jean pierre sueur soit
propulsé en star médiatique de nos
positions politiques
c'est mais qui leur est dit oxymore
c'est moi je trouve ça génial
alors pourquoi et est sans doute qu'il
n'y avait pas d'ambition je crois pas
que gérard lâché au départ se disaient
tiens je vais prendre la lumière ça va
être super c'est bon alors pourquoi ça
arrive je vais dire ce que je vais
reformé vous trouvé ça génial parce que
ces anciens monde nouveau
nous je trouve ça intéressant parce que
emmanuel macron par soit par un concours
de circonstances soit par une très
grande habileté politique et
probablement les deux a réussi à faire
table rase à éradiquer toute figure
politique autre que la sienne
il n'y en a pas au gouvernement il n'y
en a pas de route parlement en tout cas
c'est plutôt une voix qui accompagne
plutôt qu'ils ne voient qui oppose
il n'y en a plus au parlement où il a
quand même réussi à non seulement avoir
une majorité mais dans le mali temps a
atomisé le ps et a atomisé les
républicains or avant dans l'ancien
monde
on avait et ça n'a rien à voir exclue en
marche mais dans l'ancien monde vous
aviez des députés socialistes et
républicains avec une voix forte
une personnalité forte et qu'on
entendait et oé oé oé ministre vous
aviez des ministres avec des couacs en
série et des jeux puisque je veux dire
par là c'est qu'on avait une bien oui
s'il était blanchi qui s'exprimait sur
l'apache en hausse à a été totalement
rétabli éradiquée par emmanuel macron
que reste-t-il fda n'a pas ce qui ne
l'avait pas anticipé qu'à aucun moment
il s'est dit la révolution viendra de
jean pierre sueur de phily balle de
gérard larcher et le banc de brouillard
jour d'or et donc pourquoi je trouve ça
génial parce que ça veut dire que notre
démocratie c'est là où je pense que
l'ancien monde nouveau monde il faut
quand même fortement relativisé une
constitution qui fonctionne jusqu'à
preuve du contraire
et malgré cela la tentation soit d'un
concours de circonstances d'une volonté
de quand même mettre tout le monde au
pas globalement parce que c'est ça et
bien c'est comme les gaulois il reste le
sénat nous avons le poker
vous pousse un peu loin c'est papy fait
de la résistance c'est paris l'idée que
peut-être les gens du nouveau monde
n'avait pas anticipé la capacité de
résilience à la fois des institutions et
aussi de personnalités qui étaient
ancrés dans des dans des territoires et
qui représentent encore des encore des
choses et donc c'est peut-être aussi
pour cela que il y a eu des très bonnes
audiences aussi télévisuelle au moment
de la retransmission de ce procès et
c'est parce que toute une partie de la
société fluxys y en a comme mission
c'était une mission d'information qui
ont suivi ça avec intérêt parce que
justement il se passait quelque chose et
que le scénario écrit à l'avancé ne se
déroulait pas comme il est exactement
prévu et on note quand même envie de
croire qu'ils ont fait un peu par
conviction et je rappelle que maintenant
c'est menacer le dossier est
effectivement on n'a pas les mains de la
justice sont évidemment pas les
sénateurs les juges ils ont exprimé une
conviction à l'issue d'une enquête
maintenant le procureur a plusieurs
options soit le classement sans suite
soit l' enquête préliminaire soit l'
enquête judiciaire stéphane bern est
quoi qu'il arrive ça va être une bombe à
retardement c'est une bombe à
retardement pour emmanuel macron il
aurait tout intérêt à déjà écarté les
trois collaborateurs
elle est poussée vers la sortie non non
non pas du tout en fait cédé c'est pas
une bombe à retardement c'est une boum
tout court encore une fois le messie
puisque la con non mais alors si on
était dans un autre contexte où chacun
avait gardé raison garder et c'est enfin
le une une d une des façons il peut-être
la meilleure façon de gérer tout ça pour
les membres de la majorité ce serait
dire bon bah le sénat at a bouclé sa
commission
voila voila sont ces conclusions elles
seront transmises à la justice nous on
est confiant on sait que on sait qu'il
ya rien et donc on sait que ce sera
classée sans suite ou c'est que et donc
on est finalement le le prendre les
choses à bas bruit ou
minima aurait été à mon avis la
meilleure là mais la meilleure la
meilleure mais oui mais ils sont
fébriles mais pas forcément à cause de
la commission encore une fois ça
intervient à un très très mauvais moment
on l'a dit à plusieurs reprises et
qu'est ce qu'ils savent les
parlementaires dedans marche ils savent
que il ya deux choses il ya deux procès
où il ya deux il ya le temps de la
justice
et puis elle procès médiatique le
problème de cette de cette histoire
c'est qu'en intervenant maintenant dans
un contexte qui est particulièrement
complexe
ils savent très bien que la machine
médiatique va se mettre à tourner et
qu'on parle quand même de procédures qui
sont un petit peu complexe de dossiers
qui sont un petit voile à vin même
benjamin griveaux que la première fois
qu'il s'exprime et reconnu qu'il n'avait
pas lu le rapport
je pense qu'il ya 99 points 99 % des
français comparent lu le rapport du
sénat mais chacun est en train de se
faire un film vous avoir un avis sur les
choses et finalement le procès effet
avant même que la machine judiciaire se
met en route et c'est un procès
médiatique et une déformation naturelle
spontanée de toute l'histoire et je
pense que c'est là dessus que la
majorité présidentielle réagi très
vivement de manière très dynamique en
disant on va on va s'en prendre plein la
figure alors que et du cou d'où toutes
ces réactions qui est mon ami sont
disproportionnées trop forte et qu' on
n'aurait pas eu dans un autre contexte
oui parce que non mais le mal est fait
si vous voulez je veux dire qu'à partir
du moment où il ya suspicion vont
ensemble d'affaires suspicion passe par
le filtre des médias dans l'opinion big
souvent comme suspicion égale
culpabilité de manière
même si les sudistes à savoir le fait
d'en parler mais deux gaillards ya un
résumé qui se fait à l'action pénale et
donc le mal est fait ensuite
effectivement bon il faut attendre et
c'est là où je te dis que si le
procureur du mais finalement il n'y
avait rien à voir les pétards mouillés
5e revient dans revient devant le sénat
mais pourquoi pas seulement de l'impact
médiatique pourquoi parce que depuis le
départ
qu'est-ce qu'on a eu comme départ à
cause de cette affaire
gérard collomb ministre de l'intérieur
bruno roger petit bond porte parole mais
on l'a oublié
ismaël et mollien l'éminence grise
d'emmanuel macro à chaque fois il ya
d'autres raisons mais au fond il ya un
peu ça et encore hier et avant-hier
michel delpech le préfet de police dont
on nous explique qu'il aurait aussi payé
la ferme et nahla c'est pour ça que je
regardais 3 ou collaborateur de l'elysée
doit-il les écarter est-ce que ce c'est
à dire se ménage nom pareil il est pas
ils sont nullement mis en examen pour
quand même d'aller dire les choses dont
six maintenant d'habitude vous savez
quand vous faites un article 40 du code
de procédure pénale j'ai eu à en
connaître
vous ne la personne qui est incriminée
ne le sait pas parce que vous voyez
qu'il y à un dysfonctionnement quelque
chose qui nous paraît illégale et en
tant qu'autorité publique vous êtes
obligé de le dénoncer aux procureurs
dont vous commencez pas à écrire à la
personne qui a acquis vous qu'elle vous
pensez que c'est peut-être un escroc un
voyou que peut-être tué un escroc est un
voyou d'auge écrit au procureur pour te
le signaler non certainement pas là ces
personnes le savent elles ne sont pas du
tout mise en examen ces deux procureurs
de la république d'estimer s'il doit
poursuivre ou pas j'ai peur pour lui
parce que je connais ce procureur qui
est un éminent magistrat sauf qu'il
vient du cabinet mme belloubet et qu'il
a fait une partie et que donc et que
donc quelle que soit sa décision elle
sera mal interprété par tous ceux qui
veulent instrumentaliser la justice
et ça c'est bien dommage c'est bien
dommage car c'est un procureur je le dis
je connais par ailleurs admirable c'est
un grand magistrat
et ce n'est pas une position facile qui
est la sienne il obéit à je rappelle
le procureur il rend compte au parquet
et donc est donc en fait au garde des
sceaux aussi je voulais juste complété
j'avais pas fini ce que vous disiez
est-ce qu'il doit écarter
je n'en sais rien ce que je n'ai
certainement pas de conseil à donner au
président la république je voudrais
juste constater qu'il n'a écarté
personne sauf les gens qui n'ont pas
enfin c'est plutôt les gens qui n'ont
pas voulu porter le chapeau à la place
de la présidence qui ont été écartés ce
que je veux dire c'est que il n'y a pas
eu de sanctions et on a bien vu à quel
point le licenciement de monsieur
benalla est venu tardivement les gens
qui sont partis sans souvent des gens
qui n'ont pas voulu porter le chapeau ou
à qui on a renvoyé la balle
donc je ne crois pas je ne sais pas s'il
doit le faire mais je ne crois pas vu la
pratique jusqu'à présent de cet exécutif
qu'il va vu ses déclarations sur la
république des fusibles qu'il va se
séparer de personnes qui ont plutôt
protéger le président de la république
dans leurs déclarations
alors ça semble plus anecdotique mais ça
ne l'est pas tant que ça et c'est le
dernier point que je voudrais aborder
avec vous parmi les autres conséquences
politiques il ya les tensions entre l
air et les centristes hervé marseille
quel président du groupe vous dit non
mais vous allez lire ce que dit hervé
marseille président du groupe des
centristes qu'ils étaient contre cette
décision du bureau du sénat il ne mâche
pas ses mots
je prends acte de cette décision mais je
continue de penser que cette démarche
était inopportune philippe bas et bruno
retailleau ont pris le bureau en otage
face à un axe durée ler ps qui signe
cette affaire je m'interroge sur la
solidité dans les semaines à venir de la
majorité que nous formons nous
centristes au sénat avec les
républicains vous dites non jérôme
bascher mais c'est presque une menace
non il a géré il avait pris c'est une
position dans les médias hervé marseille
avant la position qui ressort n'est pas
totalement celle qui le qu'il avait mis
le rapport de volée mais le rapport de
valérie létard qui me semble et
vice-présidente du sénat issu de son
groupe a été juste là le droit rien que
le droit et des voies ont été vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure je crois je
n'étais pas au bureau entièrement à jean
marc gabouty il ya des solutions qui ont
été trouvés
et avec une discussion et donc pas
voulais me contre je comprends je
comprends la gueule je comprends
l'agacement
je comprends la déception cependant la
majorité sénatoriale est au travail le
sénat est au travail est alors en aucun
accord avec total mais c'est normal
ceux qui se sont exprimés avant peuvent
être déçus après donc voila et chaque
chose à sa place et non respectés que le
droit et je peux vous dire quelque chose
et je m'inscris là en faut c'est
l'absence l'absence totale que philippe
bas et bruno retailleau de pressions
auraient pu faire sur qui que ce soit
sur qui que ce soit et je le dis bien
clairement et philippe bas c'est après
avoir transmis rapport ne s'est
nullement exprimé à aller voir ses
collègues d'autres l'ont fait d'autres
l'ont fait d'autres l'ont fait et bruno
retailleau a expliqué au groupe
je peux le dire je peux le dire a
expliqué au groupe que c'était à chaque
membre du bureau de s'exprimer dans
toute sa liberté dans toute son
indépendance et qu'il en aurait en
aucunement une conséquence vis-à-vis de
ses membres du bureau et voilà c'est la
liberté savez les sénateurs sont grands
indépendant nous avons l'habitude de
dire en avant calme et droit comme à
saumur c'est là l'expression de gérard
larcher
nous continuons dans cette voie là mais
la majorité du groupe et la rm bien être
une idée donc oui bien sûr mais il ya un
fonctionnement moi je comme miss et dans
le fonctionnement dans le fonctionnement
interne dans l'euro perdait ce jeu ne
croit non non non mais on peut avoir je
veux dire que ça met pas en cause le
travail parlementaire parce que
effectivement je pense qu'on est capable
les uns les autres de garder
suffisamment de liberté pour se
retrouver sur un certain nombre de savon
nombre de textes servant d'amendements
moi j'aurais préféré d'ailleurs que
lorsque on veut non pas s'opposer mais
de ce qu'on veut je dirais essayez de
un de faire valoir ses arguments on le
fasse plus sûre sur les idées sur les
collectivités territoriales ou le sénat
quand même une carte à jouer ou
président a été il s'était améliorée ces
dernières semaines mais il a été il
était maladroit dans la forme alors que
sur le fond parce que les gouvernements
précédents peut-être pas fait mieux ou
peut-être même fait moins bien notamment
en termes de ponction dotation donc
c'est un petit peu regrettable
je ne pense pas que ça me bouleverse la
vie la vie la vie au sénat moi je
partage tout à fait les positions de
d'hervé marseille mais je veux dire que
c'est pas ça qui doit avoir une
incidence sur les chaussures les sur les
textes qui vont être examinés jeudi avec
la loi mobilité
on va continuer à examiner comme s'il
n'y avait pas eu de d'affaires
d'affaires pénales dont le rail
parlementaires n'ont ensuite dans les
relations qu'on peut avoir ou pas avec
le gouvernement ça c'est autre chose on
veut très vite moi je trouve quand même
que les propos d'hervé marseille ne sont
tant qu' il peut y avoir peut-être une
recomposition ou d'une évolution des
rapports entre les différents groupes
on ferait sûrement indépendant galère ce
serait très bien et est pourquoi on voit
bien qu encore une fois toute cette
histoire sortira tir du site et une
incroyable histoire à tiroirs et à
chaque fois que vous voudrez à tiroirs
ou fait un polichinelle qu'il se vend
bien et on se demande bien quand est ce
que la commode aura été épuisée non non
je suis complètement d'accord et on a du
mal à comprendre même pourquoi cet effet
deux tiroirs et avec du recul un jour on
saura pourquoi cette affaire en
apparence très localisées au niveau de
l'exécutif aura eu cet impact s'était
fait bombes à fragmentation et les
historiens feront ce travail à notre
place merci à tous les phoques d'avoir
participé à ce grand débat fin de cette
édition spéciale car lynch et la guerre
je rappelle quand même la une de loeb
cette semaine spéciale immobiliers tout
ce qui change merci à vous et moi je
vous retrouve lundi en direct à 18h pour
un nouveau numéro de bpl et puis
l'invité de territoire d'infos demain
c'est ugo bernalicis députés leur
conscience au mythe du nord très bonne
soirée reste au coeur du débat
[Musique]
oh